Apple's iPhone 16 lineup is going to be
incredible and now that we're in 2024
we're only a few months away from the
big reveal where Apple's going to show
off their brand new larger design
updated displays the new additional
capture button and so much more
especially on the inside so in this
video I'm going to share seven brand new
very important leak updates that we just
got and yes these are all new leaks that
I didn't mention before in previous
videos getting right into leak update
number one we have the action button
design for the iPhone 16 lineup and it
looks like apple has finally decided on
what they're going to do with it Apple's
recently been tweaking the design of the
action button and changing the sizing
and some rumors were pointing to it
being a larger and longer action button
exclusively for the 16 Pro Models why
well because the regular 16s were
rumored to finally get the action button
so so they wanted the Pro Models to
still seem and look special now some of
the leaks pointed to Apple using a
capacitive action button which had a
flush look on the design instead of
looking more like a button like we have
right now and there were even leaks of
Apple unifying the volume buttons into a
large Rocker with a cut in the Middle
with a small action button above it so
we just got a new Leak with the latest
Pro 2 development stage and apple is
apparently sticking to the current
design no changes at all for the 16 Pro
while the regular 16 models are going to
be getting the new action button and
apparently Apple's going to be saving
all the major changes for the iPhone 17
now moving on to leak update number two
this one is going to be huge for the
regular iPhone 16 and 16 plus according
to the Apple analyst Jeff Pooh the new
basic iPhone 16 models will now finally
come with 8 G gabt of RAM and Wi-Fi 6E
support just like we have on the current
15 Pro Models right now I've been using
my 15 Pro Max for a few months and this
is the first phone where I have no
issues whatsoever with multitasking and
apps no longer resetting like they did
before it's just been an amazing
multitasking experience and it makes
sense since you have the same amount of
ram 8 gigs as you have on the M3 MacBook
Pro now the more interesting part about
this leak is that the iPhone 16 and 16
Pro Models are rumored to be getting the
a18 and a18 pro chips now my theory is
that both of those chips will actually
be the same physical chip but the a18
pro will be coming with exclusive
features and more of the cores enabled
and my theory now finally has some proof
now that we see that both models are
coming with 8 gigs of RAM making it
easier to manufacture them but as far as
the Wi-Fi the iPhone 16 Pro Models are
rumored to be getting Wi-Fi 7 which is a
big upgrade getting to number three
we've got to talk about another big
feature that's going to be exclusive to
the 16 Pro Models which is the latest
Snapdragon
x75 5G modem now this leak also came
from Jeff Pooh just a few days ago and
it's really disappointing for a couple
of reasons but first I've got to show
you the absolute best Max safe car
charger that'll support not only the
iPhone 16 but even the current iPhone 15
models from our sponsor ESR which is the
number one brand of Max safe accessories
on Amazon with
368,000 plus five-star reviews this
right here is the world's first ch2 max
saave car mount charger which can
finally charge your iPhone at the full
15 watts of power just like Apple's
official 15 wat Max saave so it's just
as fast but much more affordable since
they don't have to pay Apple the royalty
fees so they can lower the price down to
only around 36 bucks that's an
incredibly good deal even for a basic
car charger but this one supports 15w
ch2 which is just insane and it even
features two secure mounting methods and
either an air vent or on the dashboard
for maximum flexibility with highly
customizable viewing angles so use a
link in the description below to order
it today as well as checking out esrs
entire ch2 Max safe charger lineup
getting back to the new x75 modem first
of all the current regular iPhone 15
models came with the same new x70 modem
as the 15 Pro Models which was a big
surprise because that modem is just so
good as soon as I upgraded to this 15
Pro Max the 5G service has been
incredible it's been a lot better at my
house while I'm on the road switching
between Wi-Fi and my wife even noticed
Noti that when we're at Spirit Lake
camping in the Summer she can finally
make calls on her new 15 Pro whereas the
previous 14 pro wouldn't even initiate a
call it would just cancel right away the
modem was not good enough but now it is
so it's really exciting that the 16 Pro
will be getting the new x75 modem which
will be even better and apparently it's
going to use 20% less power leading to
better battery life and less overheating
but it's disappointing that the regular
16 is no longer getting the flagship x75
Modem with the new 5G Advanced feature
which should have much improved
performance now for leak number four
this actually has to do with Apple's
biggest rival on the Android side
Samsung for the first time ever Apple
has shipped more smartphones annually
than Samsung which is a huge deal
because the average sale price for a
Samsung phone is much lower because they
sh a ton of budget phones but in terms
of the leaks we've already seen the
Galaxy s24 ultra's leaked performance
benchmarks with that new Snapdragon 8
gen 3 chip and it's looking really good
for the future iPhone 16 models with the
A8 and a18 pro chips now for update
number five this one's a bit
disappointing for the new iPhone 16 Pro
Models based on a report from Digi times
the 1 terby SSD models could see worse
performance than we currently have on
the 1 TB 15 Pros apparently Apple's
going to try to reduce their expenses on
the new models by switching to more
available and less expensive quad level
cell nand flash memory for the stor
Apple's currently using a triple level
cell which is much more expensive
because it's able to keep the
performance High even when transferring
large amounts of files quad level
storage allows four bits of data into a
single cell instead of three which
increases the capacity while using the
same footprint size which makes it
cheaper to produce but it leads to
slower performance and lower life
expectancy since it's a bit more
complicated to transfer the extra bit
into the cell back and forth but I guess
Apple needs to do this because they're
currently only charging 200 bucks more
for the one terabyte storage option over
the 512 so their profits are currently
low on that up upgrade but I think it's
mainly because of another reason which
brings us into update number six that we
just got the other day according to a
Korean Tech blogger the new iPhone 16
Pro Models will apparently come with a
new 2 tbte storage option for the first
time ever which makes sense now that
we're recording more video and it's
becoming a bigger deal especially with
the Vision Pro headsets that's one of
the reasons why Apple's adding the new
capture button to to the 16 Pro just for
recording video which takes up much more
storage space but it seems like this new
2 TB storage upgrade is only coming
because apple is switching to qlc or
quad level cell storage allowing them to
get it for cheaper and not pass that
price down to us charging us crazy
amounts of cash to upgrade and finally
let's finish off with number 7 which is
a recent link that we got from Ming chiw
apparently the new iPhone 7 17 next year
is going to be coming with a brand new
24 megapixel front-facing camera greatly
improving the image quality for selfies
with a new six element lens and this is
going to happen hand inand with the
iPhone 17 being the first iPhone to
feature underpanel face ID technology
which is likely going to allow them more
space for a bigger selfie camera sensor
but what does that mean for the iPhone
16 Pro well it means that we shouldn't
expect any any camera changes at all on
that front we'll still be getting the
same old 12 megapixel selfie cam but the
good news is that the iPhone 16 models
will be getting a new 48 megapixel Ultra
wide camera on the back and the 16 Pro
will finally get the 5x camera like the
pro Max has which is my personal
favorite camera there you guys go
hopefully you enjoyed this iPhone 16
leak updates video so there you guys go
but there you guys go hopefully you
enjoyed this iPhone 16 leak updates
video and if you did you can subscribe
above and check out our thoughts on the
Vision Pro headset right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next
[Music]
video